[Music]
my friend nick frost very funny actor he
does a bit with his friends that is one
of my favorites in a restaurant in a
public place they'll sing their happy
birthday song like people do happy
birthday to you they all join in and
then at the end of the song they do
another verse
so it's like happy birthday to you
so it's your birthday
how are you feeling you know whatever it
is and they've all memorized it so
they'll sing it together
and he said the look on people's faces
when
they realized that there's another verse
to the song that they didn't know about
i've never seen it i've never witnessed
it personally but just the thought of it
is so funny to me and then at the end of
that fake second verse they go back into
so
happy birth and they do
the first i thought he was the one who
did that just hap
no i don't know who that is that's
really funny that's my favorite oh yeah
when you just say sit in a crowded place
and you go
and to try to get other people to join
in yeah to a non-birthday song so the
intro version of that to this show would
be your
or should
yeah life could be a dream life could be
a dream
anyway you are listening to life is
short i'm your host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
with me as always is uh my bit loving
brother you like a good [ __ ] i thought
you were about to call me a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
is my [ __ ] brother uh i don't think we
can say that why well you can call him i
can call you a [ __ ] i know that's what
you're saying no okay all right yeah so
you can't be so sensitive i know and you
can be a [ __ ] thanks
[Music]
give me an example of the last time i
was about oh man well this morning wow
when there were there were
guys working on the like around the
house like doing yard work like tough
stuff the stuff that i should be doing
and uh he's the [ __ ] now
i know i know but this was right a
mouthful of smoothie as i said that
that's
oh no there you go
that was the last step
[Laughter]
uh and you had you were holding a cup of
coffee an empty cup and you said oh i
need another cup of coffee but it was
like 10 o'clock yeah
i guess that qualifies yeah uh happy
birthday song
hap it's really funny and then people
kind of stop or when it's somebody's
birthday and they haven't done the happy
birthday song you get more excited about
public happy birthday songs than anybody
i know
do you know that you get like you get
upset when like if you're in a
restaurant people aren't singing if
other tables aren't joining in you like
look around and you wave your hands like
why isn't everyone singing yeah and i
think people usually like
that kind of attention from strangers
right like if it's your birthday and
you're in a restaurant you want to be
you already want to be publicly
uh celebrated for it right so the more
the merrier well here's the weird thing
i
get very embarrassed when people sing
happy i mean
you know i've done stuff on stage i've
been in front of large crowds i
but i get for some reason get really
embarrassed when people sing happy
birthday to me in a restaurant oh but
you're comfortable embarrassing other
people well i like celebrating other
people it's not that i want them to be
shamed maybe sometimes it is
i don't know if if it's a friend
somebody i'm really close with and i i'm
busting their
balls or their chops mm-hmm maybe you
say busting your busting your chops
busting your body either
um
yeah but i like i like when a whole i
also like the idea that you like
marriage
i like merry men and it's true that's
true and i like when a whole restaurant
of strangers you also like shaming
people occasionally and i think part of
it is
when kind of like sullen looking
restaurant goers especially if they're
participating in something that everyone
kind of should be participating yeah
yeah that's like the unspoken thing in
our society that like everyone
should sing a happy birthday in a
restaurant if i think i think i agree
it's also not that hard it's so easy and
it lasts ten seconds unless you're doing
the more
that's so funny which i love uh i know
and i how good does it feel when a whole
restaurant of people
chime in i just like i like it i like
encouraging people to do it it's like
that scene in planes trains on
automobiles when the whole bus starts
yeah three coins and a fountain do you
know this one no
i think communal singing
i think communal singing in general is a
positive thing that's why oh yeah church
when everyone's singing it's it's groups
that are singing i enjoy
yes well
then why are we talking about groups
singing and or anyone saying good
question thanks i'm usually not the one
to pivot to that i know hey
are you are you disappointed that yeah i
also feel like the pivot to the reveal
of who the guest is is stupid because
when you click on the show you know who
it is you know who it is so it's not
like sure all right everybody here it
comes we want to
bury the surprise yeah it's josh groban
growband
you know i have trouble with this god i
can't believe well i didn't ask him for
the respoiler alert we don't find out
grow ban i just we just call them grobs
it's it's either
josh groban it's like or josh groban
josh greg how much work do you put into
pronouncing that a joe rogan joe rogan
joe rogan josh groban oh okay let's do
that
names but i know but the robin josh
groban
same construction of leather all right
let's go with josh groban
groban i just grow band that sounds
weird to me now well it's called groves
okay like with like i called gerard
butler g butts
um
so j groves uh is an old
i don't know what to call it old
acquaintances in hollywood turns you
know when you you meet somebody briefly
at the chateau marmont or whatever and
you have a night you know when you just
like meet somebody and
you're introduced to somebody whatever
we were on a we were on a talk show
together at gordon show
james corden and so we
i met him on the show i really like
usually those things are kind of like
him i liked him so much and i was like i
remember thinking i don't know if we
talk about this i don't think we do but
i remember thinking i could be friends
with this guy
which is very rare for me i well
especially at this age i like his voice
as a and i think that can be said about
uh millions of people around the world
yeah
he is a world renowned
artist he's just awesome here he is uh
josh groban
life could be a dream sweetheart
i should have a better knowledge of
recording and musical technology uh but
you know i was signed at 17 years old
and i was a i was a theater kid i wasn't
like i wasn't somebody i wasn't making
music in my making beats in my bedroom
so i wasn't i wasn't big on the
technology to begin with and then and
then when you get discovered by a super
producer and all of a sudden you're like
walking into their mansion and they've
already got a studio
set up and oh you don't have to worry
you just all i mean i had a big thing i
had to worry about which was to sing my
ass off and not [ __ ] up but i always had
the most incredible
engineers and
i was yeah you've never had to learn i
never really did because my music is
more traditional because a lot of the
times i mean i have been so spoiled but
i but i would you know we would do
things the old-fashioned way we'd be in
the room with the musicians or with the
orchestra or whatever it is
i would just come in with tea and be
warmed up and have the song learned how
did that happen at 17 because i know i i
had read that you were a theater kid you
loved theater you did a lot of i was i'd
imagine i was like i was born raised in
l.a you know my parents are very
artistic they never went into um
professionally my mom was an art teacher
um and then she kind of went into
philanthropy and some other things but
my dad was a trumpet player jazz trumpet
player all through college incredible
trumpet player and then his mom said
that's no way to make a living so he
went off into business and so i've got
two really artsy parents that were very
real real world so did your dad ever um
not regret regrets the wrong word but
did he miss did he ever feel like he
missed out on a journey into the arts
like going full i don't think so because
i mean he's great at his job and he's a
great fan of music but i think that
actually what wound up happening for him
is that because
he stopped playing the trumpet he was
allowed to keep loving
jazz and loving music in a way that had
no pressure
right you know i think i think that he
just was allowed to just be a fan you
know for his life and you know who's to
say if i mean he was great we have his
old recordings he was wonderful was he
so prolific that he could have been
listed among the greats i'm not sure you
know i love my dad but i'm not sure so
uh probably not so um do you ever do do
you ever fantasize about that about uh
what happened to your dad i mean like
that you would continue to sing you
would get to sing purely for fun and it
wouldn't be a source of stress or
pressure in your life well there's an
interesting thing happening i think
during this
pandemic for those of us that are in the
creative field where all of a sudden
we've had our wheels have ground to
grind it to a halt where all of a sudden
this kind of go go go hamster wheel of
what's the next tour bus what's the next
venue what's the next responsibility
when do i need to you know put another
song under the door of my label
and all of a sudden we're
we're all on a timeout every one of us
there's really like no way for us to do
anything except
sit with our thoughts right because we
love it raise money when we can for for
places that need it and um and just kind
of reflect and uh and so i think that
that's that's been you know just as
crazy making for those of us that just
really want to get back to work i'm very
privileged and that i want to get work
back to work i don't need to get back to
work there are so many people that that
are desperate to get back out there um
so i i fully appreciate that um but i
know josh i've been having these
conversations with creative people such
as yourself so i always feel the need of
course to preface it by acknowledging
sure how lucky we are yeah we're so
lucky and i think it is i think in a
time when we are looking for a silver
lining i think the world wants to have
some kind of hope because as much as
we're grieving and as much as we're
anxious about the times that we're in
it's human nature to want to think about
a better tomorrow we want to know that
when we come out of this because we will
at some point come out of this whenever
it is
that you know it is a waste if we
haven't learned something if we haven't
if we haven't grown from it um that that
they're not mutually exclusive we can be
angry we can be grieving but we can also
you know use what we can from this to
say
okay well what came out of it that was
better for for not just you know me or
you but for all of us i you know i i
flexed gratitude every single day for
the simple things i yeah i found a way
to create out of sheer love of creation
and not because of another gig i had to
do next week isn't that nice has it
reminded you of that i mean what are
what have you been reflecting on besides
the fact that you're able to grow an
incredible beard
it's not all not always the case uh when
i was i that the beard game started to
happen like when i was like 27 28 it
finally my my russian ukrainian jewish
roots started to
where have we've been here we've been
all these years
yeah uh and suddenly uh no i i played
speaking of musical theater i played a
character in uh when i was 16 years old
that needed a beard and they had to they
used to they used one of those sponges
makeup sponges with like the oh that's
what i did like
yeah i played reverend hale in the
crucible like one of the old
cantankerous
officious ones and i was i didn't go
through puberty until
much later i mean i started
in the high school
i was a little yeah
yeah i was a late bloomer too so i mean
again that seventh grade sucks when your
voice hasn't changed yeah oh yeah well
especially for a singer yeah especially
for a singer i but the thing is that i
because i was like my voice didn't
change until like thirteen and three
quarters
i um you know and that's a summary when
exactly no i'm kidding yeah well i
remember the day like it was yesterday
it was february 12th and where's my
captain crunch
oh it was between breakfast and lunch by
the way just because it changes doesn't
mean it's nice to listen to
oh my god yeah my brother we were just
laughing at my brother and i were uh
i have a place on this lake and speaking
of lucky and yeah and there were kids
there were teenagers nearby and uh
playing on the
on the lake and you know they you could
tell it just brought us back to that
time when we were like competing for the
attention of girls and like trying to
show off
and their voices were so
we just started pube you know when you
just hear that it's the it's like pube
that's the only word that comes together
yeah and it's like and you think you
think you sound like such a hot shot
because yeah because up until that
moment you haven't
felt the resonance in your chest of
having had your voice changed so when
you're talking like this you're like i'm
a man now and yeah surely when i speak
it will command attention from my peers
and from the opposite sex
yes yeah and i i command respect
yeah before this i had to demand respect
now
i'm merely commanded it's like it's like
the teenager and the simpsons okay sir
yeah oh truly there's a character for
every part of us on that show yeah and
they're always oh my god yes uh but um
my voice didn't change till 13 didn't
start to sound
remotely singable until 15 and then i
was signed at 17. so oh my god so it was
that it was a rocket boost of pressure
and anxiety and and and also like ego
boost at the same time so i had all this
like like both of these things
converging at once where all of a sudden
i was getting all these high fives and
then i was like going home and feeling
like a piece of [ __ ] all night long so
it was a lot to kind of take on and and
i'm thankful that it wasn't happening
during the time of twitter and you know
social media and
now to be a new artist you have to be a
new artist
on so many other platforms than just
releasing music and people buying it and
listening to it people have to know your
day-to-day social media they have to
know your tick-tock dances they have to
know your your relationship in and out
they have to you know it comes with the
game now that if you're going to be even
remotely famous you have to get trolled
by a million bots you know every single
day and that messes with your
self-esteem and i was dealing with
anxiety and depression and stuff back
then so i mean no i was i was i had to
learn how to like how to get a thicker
skin as an adult because i was a young
17 year old too i mean
i was singing for older people and i was
singing really heady kind of traditional
music but inside i was i was just i just
wanted to play my super nintendo and
drink you know capri suns yeah i was a
kid well anxiety and depression that
just came from uh
teenage
regular teenage trauma or
i was just like a really over thinking
kid i was late to be diagnosed with adds
so i didn't know during my school years
like why i was falling behind
and so whereas i was just getting kind
of scolded all the time and i was
getting
you know told by the teachers like well
he better keep up he's just not he may
not be smart enough and it wasn't until
later on that i realized that it had
nothing to do with iq or smarts or
anything like that it was just a
different way of learning and now the
school systems are adjusting and
allowing for kids to learn in different
ways and it is getting better it's a
huge reason why i think arts education
is so pivotal in our schools because it
opens up different ways for kids to
transform and digest right information
in other subjects and was that something
that you had at your disposal were you
exposed to that uh you said your mom was
a was an arts teacher yeah she she
understood and and
thank god for my parents who were so
wonderful and and understanding with all
that but having arts in school in the
school just changed my life like as soon
as as soon as i was able to
express myself and use the arts as a
tool in my academic life and as soon as
i had those hours a day where i could
sing or play drums or play piano or to
be part of a show
um everything else just seemed to go
into hyper focus and it clicked it into
place and so
no i mean it's it's kind of like your
adderall it was yeah because yeah
because i tried those meds and they you
know they give us and they take us away
you know they
they give you a huge boost of energy and
focus and they are
vital for so many people i've been on
off and on them my whole life um but
then they also you know have their side
effects which can sometimes
chip away at the nuances of who you are
when you're struggling with this the
anxiety the depression and and like you
said you're what a roller coaster that
must be you're getting this ego boost
from having been signed
how do you then express that anxiety and
depression during a time when you're
being celebrated you're all these
exciting things are happening to you how
do you how do you
manage that there there were weren't a
lot of ways to to manage it because as
soon as you're shot out of the canon and
all of a sudden there's a brand whether
you like it or not you're out and that's
it that person on the billboard or on
the album cover that's who they see as
you
and you know also as people who are
artistic
that's also a part of who we are if
you're an actor you're doing a script
you get known for a certain kind of role
if you're a singer and you have a
certain kind of voice a lot of times
people can put certain narratives around
what your voice sounds like and they
assume that's that's the entire picture
of who you are and so as a young person
too i've had more fun branching out and
trying to have more of a nuanced career
to represent all the different sizes of
my brain that i want to get out there
but back then when i was terrified about
not rocking the boat not pissing off you
don't want to get off the ride i don't
want to get off the ride i don't want to
piss off the label or anybody that's
giving me this incredible opportunity
it's also still a huge part of who you
are i love singing and i love singing
that kind of music um but it doesn't
leave a lot of room for vulnerability
when you're out there and you have to be
the guy and you have to people are
looking to be moved and they're looking
to hear
your voice and hear those notes and
especially when you're a young person
you've been been put on on that pedestal
you don't want to slip um and and by the
way you know the music business is um
can at times be a very caring and
nurturing place
it can at other times be
very very cold and very um
lacking uh bedside manners even even if
you're at the top of your game there's
always going to be people around you
that
are very loving and very supportive but
then also that kind of very much like
well
you know if you if you mess up the
microphone will be passed along you know
so it's it's that's the business baby
it's it's confusing it's not there's not
a lot of ways to do it and i was living
at home for my first album so like for
me it's just like i just like went to my
room i guess you know i mean yeah and
like you said without social media
without having totally
but for better i had a landline i had a
landline
to my bedroom i remember i remember
when i was in high school and i got
finally got my landline uh i wrote it on
the marker board i said hey everybody
just want to know what you know i have a
landline if you guys feel like calling
me after school you guys want to chat
talk about homework here's my number
call anytime i remember that time that
would have been a really special thing
absolutely
1998. uh oh man i remember my parents i
remember the sound of my parents like
the few times i would talk to a girl on
the phone and it was you know the [ __ ]
you talk about pressure i mean you think
you had it rough job well i mean now you
could text and tweet and and i know it's
a lot less personal but you had to call
you had to call yeah yeah and that sat
but i remember my parents so sneaky that
that it was very faint but i could hear
like the faintest
change in the tone of the call so
someone had picked up or one of my
brothers even worse had picked up and
and you don't want to say hey get off
the phone there's somebody else on the
phone you don't want to interrupt the
flow of whatever you're attempting oh
you just have to sit with it
that whatever you yeah they might be
hearing someone's listening and you're
going to get it at dinner later oh yeah
but you just have to yeah
so uh uh you looked uh
you looked really uh pretty today uh oh
and uh oh not even oh i could never that
would be much more advanced way too way
too forward yeah wait i was i was i was
so shy that i had to do the thing where
i'd have the call a friend of mine call
the girl while i was on the line and say
so from like one to ten how cute do you
think josh is
and i'd just be like listening in the
second no please oh please oh please i
don't know is there a foreign i can live
with that
so you're saying there's a shame there's
a chance
yeah so like the next day i like did my
hair different and like
wore my other turtleneck and if josh
were to change his hair
what type of look would you be
interested in exactly
suddenly i just i bring the old pig skin
to school and start tossing it around
with my buddies randomly yeah
yeah did that stuff change i mean that
must have improved been easier anyway
when you got this record deal and all of
a sudden like because i imagine you're
still in high school in that i was uh
you know i i i started to get more
confident i mean i mentioned the arts
but it's true like i i want to i want to
i went to a couple different high
schools but i wound up graduating from
the los angeles county high school for
the arts and it was the first time i
ever felt like popular and it wasn't
because it wasn't because i got signed
to a label or anything else it was just
like
i was around my people like i was around
other kids who
you know valued the arts and valued you
know working hard at learning a song and
wanting to be part of the theater and
building sets and all that stuff like we
were a clique all of a sudden and yeah
and it wasn't just theater it was like i
was friends with the visual arts majors
and the dancers and the writers and
everything else and we all
valued that so all of a sudden the
things that made me
kind of shy and nerdy at other schools
made made me like a badass in this
little world that we're all in you know
and so and so i was lucky that for my
11th and 12th grade um
you know i finally like got a girlfriend
and like felt like i felt like i could
you know call friends to hang out and
they'd say yes and you know and i just i
felt i felt i was i was feeling myself
and and uh when you are the kid
you know singing
art songs in italian sorry josh wait
please don't forget this my mother's
face
uh hey mom you have the technology i'm
i'm i'm talking to josh groban oh what's
your mom's name there's a challenge
there's a talent wendy hi wendy
all right
we gotta go
put some put some reverb on wendy what's
that
i hope some of it
i hope some of it rubs off on you yeah i
i do too my mother's ladies and
gentlemen yes all right i'm hanging out
now everybody
i'm so glad to know that every mom
in the universe just still gives us all
[ __ ] like it's just yeah i feel like
that's such a huge part of the love of a
mom is just making making and it only
and the [ __ ] gets it gets even more
aggressive the more if you become
successful the more successful yeah
that's
in high school but then like you get
signed and you know all of a sudden
you're the you're the kid singing
traditional you know big voiced songs in
a world of like boy bands and rap rock
and i remember walking into the label
for the first time and they showed me
the musical the music the musical video
it was a moving picture of a music song
uh and it was that come on lady come
come ladies
oh my butterflies i forgot the name of
the uh they're showing me they're like
well josh welcome to the music business
this is the music business and they're
like this is you got to do your hair
like this and you got to you know if you
get a couple tattoos that would be okay
too and i'm watching him like and he's
got his frosted tips and he's like
rapping about his lady yes i know that's
how your song was in like every movie
for like two years sugar baby well who
was that not not sugar no i wanted to
say sugar sugar fish was it sugar fish
that's a delicious sushi place and yeah
come my lady come oh my god i know i'm
so sorry so that but that's but that's
what all of a sudden i'm alone at the
lunch table again like all of a sudden i
i yeah like here i have this big
lucrative record deal and and i guess
like ever i felt like every other artist
in the music business at that moment
felt like hot [ __ ] it's the equivalent
of being drafted into the nfl but i i
still felt like
uh
the team opposite you know playing
against the globetrotters you know like
i like well yes i'm senator senator i'm
still i'm well you are playing league
yeah yeah
but you're a hunter for the chat yeah i
know it's no offense to pat
my producer michelle me said uh crazy
crazy town thank you michelle thank you
yeah come my baby but not you my baby
yeah right yeah uh it's uh
that's so funny that's true josh yeah so
already so now you're kind of like back
to square one
where yeah you socially yeah yeah i mean
i didn't feel like i fit in the music
business still kind of don't and uh it's
a it's a you know it's it's a it's
you're just kind of looking around at
all the fads that are flying around
flying around and all the hype and fads
that are that are there and and you want
to fit into one of those fads and
and
you don't when you have to when you're
kind of forced to write your own
playbook a little bit it's like it's
it's isolating and if it hits as i was
lucky enough that it did then then you
feel like you've you've paved your own
path and you're like okay well all that
insecurity and weirdness was worth it
but um but no it was it was isolating
yeah was it not a comfort that these
producers who discovered you uh
were seemed so sure that you could do
this that this could that this was your
past it definitely was it was both a
boost of confidence but it was also um
high pressure because david foster you
know has discovered like some of the
greatest voices of all time and you go
into his house and you know he's got
something like 18 grammys on the piano
and he's all his platinum records for
celine and whitney houston they all fit
he finds a
way there's a will there's a big big
piano
might have been two pianos i don't even
know he didn't put the top up but
there's no it doesn't slide down he had
an extender yeah uh yeah yeah put it up
what was the grammys watch the grammys
oh that's that's
where do you put your grammys on i have
no grammys i i i have no grammys
i have a uh this is my grammy i've got a
i've got a
are we on video for this podcast we're
not yeah yeah i can see this i i got a
mic oh
we're not recording the video but so i'm
going to tell you what you're holding up
that's really cute you only have a
framed picture of your dog whose name is
grammy apparently yes yes after
grandma's not yeah music business
because uh screw this
right
right uh well but but or or like
accolades i mean you have you've won
things and have like i i
i i would say i'm like i'm i'm awards
adjacent i've been i've been nominated
for every one of the big awards
but i've never i've never won yeah i
don't have anything tony you got
nominated i was nominated for a tony it
was nominated for the capitol last year
i was nominated for but nominated four
or five grammys but i i just i fit i
don't know i
awards are are a funny thing and and you
know you always say it's political until
you get one and then you're like
that's right you like me you really like
me yeah i know i know i know but i
always but i but i will say that just
objectively like my my sound has always
kind of fit in between a couple of
different things and so like when it
comes to things like the grammys i've
just always kind of had to be at peace
with the fact that i'm never going to be
classical enough for the pavarotti
grammy and i'm never going to be pop
enough for the justin bieber grammy and
so i there really isn't i know it like
feels kind of like there's just no
category for me man no no
i have kind of just by the nature of
feeling so alone early in my career
and then when you hit it that's amazing
because you're all on your own but then
being all on your own means that they're
really you kind of slide between
between categories a little bit that's
interesting so for voters i think it's
always
even though they've been very kind to
acknowledge me with nominations like
when it comes to like like pushing the
button on it there's always somebody
that fits into that realm
that means done that exact category ten
times better and so right so it just you
know you wind up just kind of you know i
make
i make um i make tin foil
well that's ironic uh josh because i i
think that's also probably
a source of your
mass appeal which is that and the fact
that you are reaching people who may not
have
discovered those quote unquote classical
like the pavarottis and the you know the
more traditional classically traditional
voices um and i i that's in a way i
think a strength well
i hope so i mean it wasn't it wasn't by
design i mean it was it was just and one
of the reasons david foster said hell
you know i want to i want to sign you
i wasn't doing anything on purpose i was
just singing and he was he said well
this is great let's find some great
material for this my voice is always
and i think one of the reasons why i
immediately was drawn to the world of
musical theater because there is such
genre bending in musical theater and
especially now where you're
incorporating you know pop and rock and
rap and all those other things into it
is that my voice when i woke up in the
morning always did from a singing
perspective always um
fit really fit between kind of two
worlds you know it was it was big and it
was traditional sounding but i never
really was interested in singing
nesundorma and the big arias like
someone like andrea bocelli does so well
and i wasn't really ever interested in
singing
you're my butterfly sugar baby either
life could be a dream
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
i've been doing these shower songs and
uh
one of my yeah one of my top requests is
for my humps for whatever reason so
i think
lovely lady lumps
i wound up sounding like the butler from
downton abbey uh my
that's what is this so what is the
shower thing are you i was on youtube i
just posted on my youtube and instagram
look it started with you know when all
this started when the when the um
quarantine started to happen all of us
were just we'd all just come off
whatever we were doing i was on the road
i came home
all of a sudden i'm talking to my
manager and we're just like you know
this is going to be a while we're going
to be we'll be staying put and
i have viewed social media as somewhat
of a necessity
i i can't look at it too deeply because
i feel like yeah it does and has
sparked kind of more negative tendencies
for me and just kind of got me into a
validation fix you know where you're
just kind of like thirsty
you're thirsty all the time if you just
if you just look look at social media to
reach out and so i've given social media
in the last few years of a real kind of
psychological break but i think the good
thing about it and especially now and
what's kind of pulled me back into it is
that we are looking for whatever tools
we can to kind of connect with our
friends our fans and so i was doing a
billboard live concert from uh this very
spot i was sitting here in the corner of
my bedroom at my piano and um and i just
wasn't happy with the sound and so
uh i got asked to sing a couple of
really anthemic songs
and i just i don't know i took my ipad
into the into the shower just to kind of
see if the reverb would be better and it
actually kind of wound up sounding
amazing
and sometimes those little things people
just like do do that more water didn't
affect
the water didn't affect the uh no the
water stayed off thankfully i don't have
a motion sensor shower yet uh
okay but you were still fully naked you
were fully fully naked oh no no that's
that's that's a good one uh i said yes
yes i will i will sing this this
inspirational uh song with five key
changes uh i i don't have a choir but i
will be fully nude
yeah
it's gospel yes but adult gospel yes
yeah um adam and eve were they not nude
garden of eden before this thing as god
made us
and the one and the two
you've also been hosting a movie night
on that uh yeah so another thing we were
doing is um you know i've got i've
gotten uh five or six concert films that
i've done like in my career and and the
last one we did was last was last year
at madison square garden and we've never
we've never released them
uh we've never done like screenings of
them for free we've always just kind of
put them out and sold them and stuff so
we decided every couple weeks to do a
movie night where we're putting them on
uh youtube youtube youtube.com
joshgroban uh and uh and i'm and there's
like a q a in commentary so like the
cool thing about it is there's like
there's like a chat on the side and so
i'll be able to kind of tell you guys
you know about behind the scenes stuff
that was happening during certain songs
or whatever else they can ask questions
and we're watching it together and so
i'll sit and i'll be i'll be on with
them and we can talk about stuff and
it's so weird for me because we're
moving backwards we're starting with the
garden concert and moving backwards my
very very first ever like pbs concert
like live from glamorous pasadena
california
oh my god
what is that like to see you at just
it's such a i'm benjamin buttoning
myself as i'm going back through this
and it's it actually is interesting your
beard is just getting patchier exactly
just stubble you can see the chia pet
soil just dripping off my face
uh it's it's weird because i am so
deeply passionate about it while i'm
creating it and i'm listening over and
over i'm at the board we're mixing we're
editing i'm re-singing and re-singing
and then once it's out i have to be at
peace with whatever the reaction is and
just let it go
i'd say 65 of the time i'm watching it
and going
man josh you were so critical of
yourself then that was badass wait look
at those people look at that high note
look at that
it's nice to kind of look back and say
man you were such a depressive anxious
self-hating
person yeah you know and then there are
other things where i'm just like oh
thank god i smoothed out that part of my
range or or thank god i changed that you
know that that lyric later on or
whatever whatever it is i
it's both
both and i think that occasionally when
i was
thinking about going back and watching
some some of the old stuff i've done
occasionally i'll land on something uh
that i'm like oh [ __ ] i wish i had
you know had i been
more connected and maybe less um
maybe just more relaxed in in that
performance
i would have
that i could have fixed that or that
would have been that's troubles not not
being relaxed with art and especially
with performance whether it's on screen
or or in front of a microphone i mean
that i think that's that is one thing
when i if i look back on older
performances i would say that one of my
biggest regrets in a nutshell is like oh
i can see that i wasn't i was i was
nervous i could see myself nervous it
blocks what you were put on this earth
to do because you want it to go well so
badly you tighten up and your creativity
tightens up your notes tighten up
everything tightens
yeah relaxation is such a key some of
it's a little bit of a psych out though
i have to say i mean the faker to make
it thing isn't so far off i think that
for me the the tools that i have now in
my belt
as a 39 year old performer versus as a
23 year old performer is that that stuff
that would make me fidgety and nervous
and
i've i've learned to psych myself out to
to turn the anxiety into a confident
can't wait to go out and take control of
the night once i realized that
i had enough experience where okay i've
i've had now almost 20 years in the
business some some stuff's gone wrong
and i've come through it i'm still alive
and now i know that i can get through it
now i know that there are things that i
can do and i think that's just that must
take a huge waste that's experience
that's this experience and you go out
there with a lot of tools out there and
you say okay well i'm going to try and
control this as best i can i find now
my most nervous moments back then were
on the stage my most nervous moments now
are off the stage and then when i get
before you before i go on and so i i
know that i'm gonna be nervous before i
go on i pace i i like get these weird
bouts of like fatigue i don't know if
you've ever done this
where before you're going on set or if
you've done live theater or anything
else like where it's just like i just
get like i get tired like 20 minutes
before i go out and it's my it's my
nervous system just kind of flying out a
little bit
yes yes because i do still get so
nervous before a play before
you know um
yeah there's that there's no
why am i yawning i'm so amped to go out
there it's like yeah and it's just like
your body's
your body it's preserving itself your
body is so amped up and ready to go um
it's like a racehorse like getting a few
extra z's before the race like all of a
sudden you go out there
and now i relish in the opportunity to
be on the stage where here the lights
are on the people are out there i can
control the outcome
back back in my dressing room i could
not and that really terrified me
and now i'm at now i'm out here
i can sing this i can sing this i'm
going to sing well i've decided i'm
going to really relax
you know and you can control that it's
the fear of control it yeah i wonder if
josh it's just the fear of the unknown
it's just the fear like i don't know
what the audience is going to be like i
don't know if i'm going to not going to
throw up as i say my first line right um
it was doing the play i remember talking
to you but i think you were preparing
for the play you were working for
natasha we were recording together and
uh yes and i was just about to go do
broadway and
um and you know that's right we were
talking about it a little bit and james
was telling me a little bit about when
he um did one man two governors and um
yeah and which was you know it's it's uh
you know because you know you've done
you've done it it's it's yeah but i
remember you being so
you sounded like somebody who um was
going to perform for the first time both
both in terms of like how
intimidated you you sounded by and how
excited you were by the process well
there was just so much reverence i mean
i i was i just as there always will be
for me with that world just because this
fork in the road to
being in the recording world and going
and playing concerts as me
was that it was it was the most
incredible lottery ticket fork in the
road that i love with all my heart and i
i'm so grateful that i get to keep doing
it but my but my real life childhood
close the door listen to a cast
recording pretend i'm going to be that
role put on that wig you know whatever
you know sing you know stars from lim is
rob at the top of my lungs i for me the
escape and the and the joy of theater
was was in the addition of taking on our
character it was the addition of telling
a story
through somebody else's eyes
and and so and that to me was was was
part of the love of theater was the was
the pretend and the and the play of it
and that was something that i had to
find a joy in that being myself because
i never wanted to be myself nobody was
more boring in this world to me more
than myself and so
the opportunity to get on a stage josh
groban
yes that's right
and uh and so the opportunity to play a
role a really meaty role to dive in to
the the the nuances of the characters of
rogers and hammerstein or steven
sondheim that allowed me to elevate what
i thought was a was a boring anxious kid
into something so much more heightened
and interesting and great and so um
so having the opportunity to finally go
to broadway after 15 years in the
business uh yeah it weighed heavy on me
i was both i was excited i was nervous
it was like
i'll never get over it and i can't wait
to go back it was the hardest i ever
worked uh it was the most most fun i
ever had in this business truly i'm
happy for you and you've found so much
success uh in doing it like like we said
you were nominated for it but i i was
just so happy because i remember i
remember how there was something so
charming about
your anticipation of doing it and how
eager you seemed and yeah i knew that it
was you know i was unproven um you know
and it's no joke like i didn't want to
go into theater
at my first time as a stunt cast i
really wanted to do it the way i'd
always dreamed of doing it and want to
continue doing it which is to workshop
it to get it in my bones to learn it
learn it learn it unlearn it learn it
again and find newness and freshness in
it every time we do it and i know to do
that it takes time luckily because
broadway is such a long runway to get it
finally onto the stage there's a lot
that goes into it there's prep there's
rehearsals where'd you do the previews
we did we did a lot of we actually did
eight weeks of previews which is which
is a long time to do previews and we
were cutting and changing great comment
all the way through those previews so
there was a lot a lot going on um and
then we opened we got rave reviews and
then i got sick the very next day which
is like your body just just collapses
we were so excited yeah
for the next five days but um
what what did you have i i wind up
getting a sinus infection to turn into
laryngitis oh you know because because
by the way i i believe i look i'm sure
there's a lot of cast members out there
that love the the after party of opening
night and just love to celebrate and
they're built that way i'll all i wanted
to do on opening night after doing dress
rehearsals previews um you know you're
just moving non-stop until that opening
curtain it is oh yeah truly other than
hosting the tonys that is the hardest
24-48 hours that i've ever had
and and by the end of it your body is
done and then what do they ask you to do
they ask you to go do a red carpet put
on a tux drink a few glasses of wine
talk to people in a loud room right your
body is done but yeah one day was not
enough for me to recover from that i was
so
i was so tired and you know my immune
system was just shot and i think it just
it it my body thought that i was done
and i wasn't
and um i just rarely get sick but i
didn't get wow wow but um yeah i'd love
to go back but that was secular
great comet was
originally off-broadway and a lot of the
off-broadway cast returned for the
broadway performance um i was able to
draw from their experience in this show
i was the newcomer but um they were so
great uh you know uh
working with people like lucas steele um
and grace grace mclean and and rachel
chavkin and ormatius people have been
part of the show for forever they were
they took time out of their schedules to
workshop with me we'd go over to the
arsenal
building and we'd run the scenes
together we'd do fight choreography a
year
a year out from being on broadway we
would just we would just wow because
because i knew i had to go on a big tour
in between that moment and when we
started rehearsals and so i wanted stuff
to take with me on the tour so that i
so that i didn't just come off of a big
tour and then like well i'm here for
rehearsal like i really wanted
the kind of
yeah i wanted the life force of that
show to be permeating in me all
throughout the tour um so that when i
came off of it i felt like i could i
could more seamlessly dive in with this
cast that had been part of the show for
so many years so it meant a lot for me
to be at that level with them when we
started the official rehearsals i did
not know you were an actor until i saw
um crazy stupid love
i remember thinking oh he's an actor
he's actually like thank you
it's not like that's not stunt casting
that's somebody who's really good at
that that was a proper audition yeah for
the cattle call for that role uh
you know i uh you know because because
it's true i was not i'm not proven in
that world and slowly but surely like
i've done enough cameos and i've had fun
like saying yes to enough fun things
where i've been able to you know not
take on the weight of this stuff just
like be on set for a few days and just
try to be like really good and funny for
the days that i have to be there yeah
and um and so it adds up look in the
music business i got a shot out of the
rocket immediately and all of a sudden
it was my name and lights in the acting
world this really meant a lot to me to
just kind of do it from square one to
audition to like be
part of it in a way that that i can
prove myself in that realm i felt that
way doing broadway i feel that way every
time i get to have a role in a comedic
thing in tv or a movie well you guys
just like i just want to do it right you
know i don't i don't want to be like
shoving myself into a project just
because i'm whoever exactly is it josh
is that less pressure because um you
know it's not like you're going out
madison square garden it's just you and
a piano was does that make it a lot
easier you're with emma stone she's kind
of helping you well i mean i mean when
you have a cast like that yeah i mean
you know the thing that the similarity
between a crazy stupid love and great
comet is that it was really an amazing
ensemble movie right and an amazing
ensemble musical too and i think you
know look i can't compare because i was
on set two days for for crazy stupid
love and
um but i had so much fun with the part
and emma's just like so fun
and relaxed on set i think a lot of it
comes down to like your duet partner so
to speak like right right because so
much of it is listening and reacting and
and sure you can have you can have
somebody who's not giving you much and
and
and then i've had and then i've had
partners like someone like emma or my
cast a great comment where it's just
like no matter what day it is no matter
what hour of the night it is no matter
whose take it is you're just getting
great stuff and you're playing and
you're and you're having fun with it and
and i think it's it's such it has to be
a team sport right i think that if
anything i i always appreciate theater
people
in tv and film because there's that
discipline of the team sportness of it
you know yes and i think that that's a
that's a mentality that is is really
very theatrical when you find people
that are from that world that come into
it's communal exactly and yeah and i
think it's quite yeah yeah sorry josh no
yeah yeah well you even mentioned that's
that was uh early on in our conversation
you said well that's one of the reasons
or that was at least a benefit um in
terms of you know when you switched to
when you went to la
uh the the art school um
that you found a group you found a tribe
i found my i found my tribe yeah exactly
and um and so whatever else you're going
through in your life you all have that
point of light
that is inspiring to you that is your
ultimate goal and that point of light is
that you just you want to reach people
you want to inspire people because we've
all sat in that audience and felt that
from right from a performance a great
play a great song and so you think to
yourself like i want to be in service of
that i want i want to do that one day i
want to be the reason i want to
you know present something in a way that
makes someone's life feel
feel better when you know sitting in
that chair you know it's a privilege to
have people sitting in a chair like that
for you and so you want to you want to
do that absolutely
is there anyone
you'd be
extra nervous to perform in front of at
this point is there anybody that you can
think of that like oh god that that's
gonna make the um the pre-show jitters
even more intense oh i think i think
anybody you loved when you were a
kid or a teenager anybody that was like
an idol of yours when you grow up and
kind of anybody that kind of helped get
you into me who would that be for you um
what
oh man
i'm actually very lucky i mean i hate to
name drop but i've been very very
fortunate in my career to have been able
to sing for sing with a lot of the
people that i've i've loved growing up
and great comet was a great way of doing
that because when you're when you're
doing almost 200 300 shows
a lot of times those people will have
been out there they went out there so
you know seeing sondheim in the audience
you know seeing bernadette peters or
mandy patinkin or
you know brian stokes mitchell or you
know all of my you know
patti lupone you know out there was just
it was just uh it was that was really
really cool and then i realized paul
simon growing up i just i loved
i loved his music and and just the
graceland album just destroyed me and so
you know i've been able to sing with him
a couple times and and i've recorded
with lady smith black mambazo now a
couple times so i've actually tried
sorry go ahead you played with paul
simon well i did we did a um we did a
concert um kind of celebrating him at
the brooklyn academy of music i guess
almost 10 years ago now and um and i was
one of the artists that was part of the
show and every so often he'd pop out and
do a do a duet and so we did bridge over
trouble together three nights in a row i
mean that was the thing about his music
growing up is that he for so many of us
he opened up my ears to so many
different styles and sounds around the
world that as a kid growing up in l.a i
would not have necessarily been able to
hear this was before you could you know
follow a world channel on spotify or
anything like that you had to go to
tower records and find it yourself so
he introduced me to the to the world
aisle you know at tower records do you
like to know who's in the audience
beforehand if it's patti lupone uh do
you want somebody to tell you or do you
prefer to just not know
yeah no i i prefer not to know i i
really do i think that you know we've
talked about nerves getting in the way
you know of just kind of greatness and
and being the best that you could
possibly be and for me i think that's
the still the thing that gets to me is
if i know someone's out there that i
appreciate or want to want to know
that's the that's the phrase i want to
do well
or whatever you try too hard god forbid
you wind up trying just a little bit too
hard as opposed to
just wanting to be the best that you
possibly can and whoever's out there to
receive it is out there that's one thing
i'm still not yeah i agree totally agree
in fact um
speaking of name-dropping sam rockwell
is a buddy of mine and whenever he does
a play
sam on his outgoing message or he used
to anyway on his on his home message he
would say uh
hey if you're looking for tickets uh
call so and so and he would leave the
number for you know his publicist or the
manager whatever and he'd say
and don't tell me when you're coming
don't tell me
he would
you have to make it clear and by the way
um steven sondheim uh is makes it makes
it actually easy on you because he knows
he's stephen sondheim
he told me beforehand
i'm not you're not going to know i'm
out there just so you know josh i'm not
going to tell you when because he knew
you know because he knows what he does
for a to a cast yeah
yeah like he he's certainly and of
course like an intermission like the
cast was tw was you know tweeting and
texting up
that he was out there but but thankfully
my heart my hardest song was in the
first action oh god yeah i'm free after
that
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
how do you take care of your voice i've
heard so many different there's
different theories and remedies and teas
and but how do you uh take care of your
voice
and avoid from getting like this he is
um you know i used to kind of over
cuddle it had an old school vocal
teacher who was just kind of treated my
voice like it was some
glass vase and it just you just couldn't
couldn't let it you know feel the wind
or it would you know crumble i've
learned since then that while that can
be true and that you don't want to put
anything in your body that would
dehydrate you or or cause any fringe on
your vocal cords or anything it also
does better the more you work it out so
i have found that like for me there's no
shortcut if i haven't been singing for a
while i'm gonna have a hard time like if
i haven't if i haven't been singing 15
songs a night i'm only gonna be able to
get through five or six before i gotta
take a break so it's it really is like
working out any other muscle so for me
you know sleep water throat coat tea
honey lemon no booze no anything else
but but then it's just like do your
scales like i know you don't want to do
it i i'm getting so far on assassin's
creed why on earth would i want
to go stand at the piano and sing the
same goddamn scale i've sung since i was
15 years old and it's so easy to
procrastinate about that kind of stuff
because it's just so boring
but um but it's important and it's so
simple it's mindless you're just doing
it but
the more i do it the better i am for the
stuff that counts
you
you notice the difference and it's
interesting um
uh and before we get into the lightning
round uh which will be very quick um i
just want to talk about you there's your
foundation it's going to find your light
it raises money for the arts yeah can
people find so it started with the josh
groban foundation and it was just like
we would give to a little bit of
everything and i started to kind of
lament on the fact that we were just
giving tossing bread crumbs to all the
giant organizations that were getting so
much more and and so i realized that my
silver bullet i testified to congress
about the importance of arts in our
world in arts education specifically and
so i said that's my silver bullet that's
that's what i want to dedicate this to
um so i and i took it away from my name
so i turn it from the josh groban
foundation to find your light which is
all about making sure and especially
right now and oh my god our funding is
about to be decimated for all of those
programs
um i've seen it change lives it's
changed my life it's not about a star
search it's about using the arts to
build
humanity and confidence and leadership
skills and it raises grades it's about
making sure that the arts is welcomed
into school programs and after school
programs and programs and that young
students and especially those in inner
cities and places where
um there aren't a lot of those programs
and especially where home home life
isn't necessarily a refuge
yes that that we have those programs for
for them to express themselves sometimes
for the first times in their entire
lives and you see behavioral problems
all of a sudden switching to
wanting to be the lead in the play you
know and it really does turn young
people's lives around and so i've been
inspired by that and and arts education
is relatively cheap to continue that's
the thing is that when you get a
donation it's such a fraction of i mean
talk about yeah even federal funding it
is such a tiny little uh it's fractional
it's both it's both angry when you don't
get the money from federal funding but
then also gratifying when you realize
that that thousand dollar donation that
one hundred dollar donation can buy
those much needed paint brushes can
paint for that that set can keep that
teacher on salary so it's it's um
there's so many other benefits that
aren't
necessarily seen but they have they pay
off huge dividends oh huge huge it
changes their lives i mean it it's um i
was lucky that it did just it did land
you know gave me a platform to
eventually find the thing that i would
find a career in but um but the vast
majority of of students that we're
reaching that's not the case and and
they will look back i talk to every day
i talk to adults um if i'm doing a meet
and greet line or something backstage or
i meet people out and they're lawyers
they're doctors they're they they work
in business they work every kind of job
imaginable that's not in the arts and
they will say that having that arts
teacher in their school changed their
lives having that arts program in their
school um gave them you know the the
nutrients the human stuff that you need
um to be better at all your other things
and uh and that's that's our goal
yeah that's really cool um okay find
your light yes sorry your question was
where they can find it uh
binderlightfoundation.org
uh what is your most commonly used emoji
josh would you say like your go-to
that you use more often than others i
mean the i love the i love the food
emojis uh i i would say though that it's
a toss-up between um the dancing guy uh
there's like a dancing disco guy that i
like a lot that like uh i don't know
just he this goes dude
he pleases me uh you're gonna get if our
text conversation has gone well you're
gonna get a disco stew oh i should be
crushing it and then the old i love the
old passive aggressive thumbs up to
people i'm working with where i haven't
quite gotten oh i can't haven't quite
gotten the answer i wanted but uh it'll
do oh
yes
i've used that yeah i don't want to say
to whom the thumbs up emoji is the new
period like it's it's yes it's almost
like
okay buddy all right buddy okay you do
you yep
yes yes
that's funny uh if you could be a
professional athlete what's a tennis
player hands down i oh i'm a big tennis
fan i love it uh
i
love playing it i had an l4 l5 back
injury so i haven't been able to play it
uh recently but um yeah i love tennis
who's your do you have a favorite i'm
not a lefty but i love watching nadal i
just he's just so he's so passionate out
there um and he's got a big loopy swung
uh very very spinny uh forehand uh and
uh i really i really admire that because
he's putting he's putting out a lot of
effort to get a really nasty spin out
there which is really great
uh if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life okay so my healthy
snack food would be edamame uh i'm
addicted to edamame uh i it's my one
weird thing on my rider is if i can get
mommy in a dressing room i love it um
already peeled already i know i like no
i gotta pop it i gotta pop it oh oh uh
pr uh
honey mustard pretzels
oh yeah ever since my high school days
there was a vending machine
uh at my high school that had these kind
of like super salty honey mustardy
little pretzel pieces and i think it was
like schneider's i think it was
something like that like roll oh god i
hope that's the name and i hope they
send me some sniders i think you're
right those not the little nubs the
little bites they're like the bites yeah
exactly yeah yeah i think it was nice
and uh
anyway hey maybe you'll get us
yeah yeah
okay so just in case they're listening
in case they're listening honey
honey mustard powder all over my shirts
and fingers uh in my near future you
know
what's your favorite movie of all time
my favorite movie of all time is a terry
gilliam cult film called the adventures
of baron munchausen oh uh
i love that movie great movie and i i
it's uma thurman's first movie yes it is
first movie and uma thurman came to our
opening night of great comet and and oh
my god and i said to her because i'm
sure she's used to getting
you know every compliment under the sun
and so i kind of like nervously said
like i love all your movies but i just
want to say i i really loved your
performance and and
and um and she goes
oh my gosh thank you so much that was my
first movie you know i was 17.
i'm like
what
yeah creeper now serious way to turn a
nice compliment no but i mean but i mean
i too was like 15 i was like 11 when i
saw it yeah no i know i know exactly but
i mean but creeper to whoever cast her
in that role i mean uh i know oh my god
well you know what's funny about i we
were talking about this the other day my
uh i was talking about with my brother
on the show about a kid i went to school
with in like sixth grade and i and i was
like this kid was like chiseled and
muscular in like sixth grade and like
super handsome and he weirdly enough
called me paul simon he used to come as
an insult but i i now consider it such a
compliment
yeah weird um but christian said my
brother said
you know i don't know if you should be
saying
for a 41 year old man to be commenting
on i said i thought well but i haven't
i'm commenting on him as though i were
to a sixth grader still right no
that's the thing and that was when i
when i complimented uma like i was
thinking of like 11 yeah 11 year old me
going to the cinerama dome yeah and
seeing her go another dime and you know
what i'm going like wow
venus is awesome
you know and uh yeah but also she's
pretty and like but she's
all the way i would have said that to
anybody in the cast that i loved your
performance in the adventures of very
much i just loved every bit of it and um
and who played the lead uh nigel uh what
was his name great actor nigel
ladies beautiful
yeah it is yeah
uh
i mean it was just it was so theatrical
you could never get a movie like that
made anymore
uh john neville john john neville
i didn't know sarah paulie was in it oh
oliver
crazy and then and then and then the
great michael caiman did the score
and it just it was you know and um yeah
we are entering the age of a reason you
know it's all about it's all about like
we must let our heads
you know take over from our hearts and
just the whole the whole message of it
was just like no we must use our
imaginations and we must have love and
yeah it was just such a such a a huge
way and there was and it was conflict it
was about a young girl's imagination
during a time of conflict and war and
how this kind of this old man comes to
them with these stories and brings them
to life and as a viewer you just you
don't you don't know if they're real or
if they're all in his imagination but
it's it's just i don't know it's it's
a little like big a little bit yes it
has a very big fish kind of feel to it
and eric idol i loved her there was a
bit of a uh
williams as the the moon god you know
uh and he had hit oh what did he was
another i did a show called the crazy
ones with robin and that was that was
one of that was one of the first things
i picked his brain about was was his
time doing baron munchausen in that role
oh what did he say he said he was
totally off script he was just like he
was just like oh terry just you know he
put me in my costume and he just he just
let me roll right you know and uh yeah
yeah so it was just i mean the cast was
incredible so yeah so a really unsung
movie if you haven't seen it it's yeah
it commands a lot of attention it's kind
of on the longer side and it's really
fantastical and weird but it really
worth it in the end
yeah i'd like to rewatch uh now that
you're talking about terry gilliam i
would like to rewatch time bands too i i
remember yeah
terry gilliam needs to do more he just
just come back to us it's just it's just
he's got such an eye
and he picks really risky things which i
think is why it's kind of hard for his
stuff sometimes to see the light of day
because he
he may be fantastical expensive ideas
okay if you that's a great answer uh if
you had to live somewhere else would
live in norway i think i would live in
like copenhagen oh i would live in
copenhagen denmark or i would live in
like bergen
norway there's something about
my mom's side of the family is
scandinavian and
every time i visit scandinavia i just
like talk about the simple things like i
just i love the design i love the
culture i love the food i just love
you know the the they're eco-friendly um
yeah i would love to go beautiful place
to live and so
yeah yeah i've always loved
just scandinavians in general i mean
that's a stereotype of people but i
always i consistently like yeah a lot
i'm always impressed by scandinavians
artsyness about them but then also like
they're kind of serious and like don't
get too ahead of yourself you know don't
get you know
yeah funny
humor
yeah yeah copenhagen i mean copenhagen
uh
okay great answer yeah um if you could
have dinner with three people dead or
alive whom you've never met never met
who would they be uh three people that
i've never met uh
or i mean somebody that like even
because i know you've met a lot of
impressive people somebody who maybe
came to the show and you think like oh
man i'd like to i'd like to actually
okay so so first uh uh
well i've i met i went i wanted to meet
meeting her but if i could i've never
had dinner with her so bernadette peters
uh uh i was too shy i was too shy
because she came
you know we all have that one celebrity
that
came on and off night like there's
there's always one night where it's like
i was battling back from a flu and i i
wasn't feeling super on and i think i
cracked a note and i just and i knew she
was out there talk about hair you can't
miss in an audience and so i've loved
bernadette peters since i was little and
i knew she was out there and i just and
i knew the show wasn't like our best
show and so i and i was so sick and so i
didn't get a chance to like
meet her and hang with her after the
show um so so bernadette would be there
uh philip glass i think would be kind of
an interesting oh i love his music uh
and uh and let's say bob marley
that would be the third oh wow whatever
eclectic
yeah
great group we might have to prod fill
up a little bit for some jokes but uh
that's all right you'll be there but
maybe he can compose
look a bob marley and philip glass
collaboration would be would be
something i would be very into god how
how cool uh yeah well you and bernadette
and then
um
yeah yeah yes just leave bernadette in
the corner we'll just
yeah yeah we'll figure out our thing uh
who's your favorite muppet my favorite
muppet
yeah speaking of bernie peters i think
she was oh yes oh yes um and i i just uh
and i just filmed uh the new the new
elmo's a new talk show uh
oh no kidding that's i i love i the
muppets are just so awesome i mean i'm
i'm i'm partial to animal i i just
i oh yeah
yeah or swedish chef
but uh
drumming and cooking are my two or two
my two hobbies now so uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna look oh okay all right that's that
it's good that that's the thing you have
in common with animal because animal
nowadays can be oh really problematic
you know oh man i i just re-watched uh
he's a cat i call the watchtower muppets
take
muppets take manhattan
uh
yeah they're all they're getting ready
to watch this movie
or or or or they're doing a review and
for the for the college audience and
they're like where's that oh no chasing
uh
temperament okay that's good uh if i
wonder in in sweden if they he's just
he's just chef why is swedish yeah yeah
he's just chef they're like yes what's
the problem
[Music]
that's really good
do you do impressions of singers of
other things like could you probably
sing yeah i mean i i that's that's what
karaoke's for is you just you know
whatever whatever they whatever they
whatever yes
oh my god that's my time to sing stuff i
have no business singing
oh that's funny my friend addison does
an incredible oh my spears like you'd
think yeah spirits are singing uh
they're who who would be
[Music]
that's really good
that's true
i don't know what else i i i
i don't know i mean throw them at me
yeah yeah exactly i'm putting you on the
spot i'm sorry
um if you could if you think of another
one uh please answer this question in
that voice um if if you could have one
superpower uh what would it have one
uh diamond
i don't know i'd fly across america
well i'd like to fly
yeah
that's funny that's good now ask me to
answer the next questions in a in an
imitation voice
yeah okay that's good um all right if
you had to be one age for the rest of
your life johnny cash what would you
pick
well i'd like to be
nine years old
it was the greatest time
had ever known
nine years old
oh nine years old
that's great
that is great that's really great um uh
if you could be
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you be crazy
town
i'm just kidding
i'd be an ostrich b b in austria
i know i can't fly but i'll run
baby
why did i pick ostrich
town is all about making poor decisions
yeah
he's a very very crazy town ostrich
yeah
i just realized lately i just saw turkey
fly uh i was up yeah i was up at my
place
and uh there's some wild turkeys around
and
in the in the woods yeah and uh this
thing just took off
like flew across the
pond
the next question is a turkey
yeah yeah okay that's good would you
rather a turkey would you rather be
called unattractive or unfortunate
so
there's that yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
need that yeah okay i asked well i mean
i guess i'd rather be called
unattractive i think i think humor's uh
you can go a long way away with you
which golden girl do you most identify
with dorothy blanche rose or sophia uh i
mean i i yearn to live my life like
sophia
uh i mean god may we all just give me a
double make that make it a double you
know i mean you know
yeah totally you come in every once in a
while with a sassy comment
but uh i think ruth i think ruth is
probably where i'm at
arose sorry rose rose was rose was the
yeah it was their mother right
oh sophia was the mother yes yes oh
roses betty white i i just totally chose
their i just chose 1989. 1989
i'm so embarrassed because i love the
show but so so who was the southern kind
of uh
oh blanche that was black
i want to live my life like blanche but
i but i but i'm probably more like
sophia
yes that makes sense yeah uh you aspire
to be a blanche
yeah then there's the turkey answer uh
which do you prefer dogs or cats
i'm a dog person yep okay that's the
right answer uh the beatles or the
rolling stones this might be um
[Music]
now that you have time to to miss
creativity and performing what are you
really jonesing to do next puppeteer
i don't know impressionist yeah i um
yeah
you're great at it i i don't know i i
i've i've got a cup i've got like two
albums in almost in the can so i'm ready
to ready to
get going on finishing those up and
getting back on the road i just missed
performing i missed theater so much i'd
love to do a musical
again i'd love to do a straight play uh
it would be a lot of fun something
comedic uh would be a lot of fun you
keep mentioning sondheim uh now i'm like
i just want to see you in a sign i would
like to i think i think um if i could
come back to broadway and doing a
do a sondheim musical that would be just
an absolute dream come true so uh we we
all got to we all got to do kind of a
zoom uh celebration of his music uh not
two not too long ago we did a big
sondheim celebration right uh and it was
just
with being yeah exactly everybody yes it
was just such a group of people and and
he was really really
thrilled with it so we were all thrilled
that we were able to do that for him
yeah that is cool what i'm i'm you know
what's nice is that you seem like you're
you're you're thrilled genuinely
thrilled by things that are happening to
you and you're lucky i mean
and i have the benefit of some
perspective now too i think that you
know when things get thrown at you
really really quickly you're just you're
kind of just a ball of nerves and ego
and you know and it's just and i think
that yeah it's i feel very lucky that i
can kind of approach things now i can
take the bad with a grain of salt and i
can take the good with a huge amount of
gratitude for the fact that i even still
get to do it and uh and and keep people
around you to keep you grounded you know
i've
have you know have
had great successes i've made you know
more than a few mistakes along the way
and uh and as long as you have people to
keep you in check and help you growing
and learning and being better it's
that's what it's about
i totally agree josh and and um this
podcast is going to be a huge certainly
will right so um listen uh yeah it is it
is so you're welcome it is a thrill
after so many years of bumping into each
other in dressing rooms uh to finally
have a lengthy discussion with you and
and
well it actually is i remember thinking
after we did that cordon show how much
how much i enjoyed just like hanging out
with you on stage which is this weird
environment where you know you can't
really
totally relax but um it was easy to
relax with you on that stage and and i
remember thinking i could be friends
with
yeah so so i'll start proposing you come
on the show right maybe once a month and
then
at by a certain point we'll be talking
every day right now i'll be here i'll be
your mcmahon um
hello yeah
um well thanks buddy i'm really glad we
got to do this
well
that happened
that's not bad it's not bad it's not bad
well
that happened i've been a i've long said
that you
are a not bad singer especially when i'm
singing a low like a lower register
singer like a johnny cash i keep a close
watch on this heart of mine that was off
you know it's not terrible his
impression of johnny cash oh my god he's
really good at that really good
really good i wanted more of that
everyone david not only was he amazing
at them yeah
but he was so
game to do all that the turkey thing he
did his turkey impression do you
remember that the animal yeah oh yeah he
did he had neil diamond that's right i
forgot
oh neil diamond was great um
that one i'm like i want to work on
because that's who i usually sing when i
sing karaoke it was
incredibly impressive you know um but i
would say as impressive as the
impressions themselves was his
playfulness in doing them yes he was
really impressive too he's a very
playful person i'm telling you he's a
you know i i never disputed it no i know
i don't know why i said it that way uh
yeah really like him he's really uh game
he's got kind of like a nerdy quipster
kind of personality yeah i like that
yeah he was like a real musical theater
nerd
yes and you know and i was friends with
those people growing up i know
you would
you guys could be friends yeah that was
any better impression oh my god that was
amazing incredible who's really good at
that you know who's great at impr
singing impressions too is ariana grande
have you ever heard her uh yeah she just
she does britney spears oh my god my
friend addison does really good britney
spears too you mentioned that in the
interview oh i did
yeah the bear is repeating it is good i
heard it really good right
yeah can you try it
um i did hit it i can't it's like
i did it i can
no i can't that's a little you know who
i just sound like a little first you
know what i used to do is uh
uh uh who's the guy with the big uh mole
um oh i don't know oh enrique glacier no
uh well he has a mole too um but i know
i love you and neville aaron neville oh
yeah he does a big map
you look like you're a baby bird trying
to get food from his mother
i'm straining so much i don't know how
much maybe i should zoom my head voice
but i know i love you that's okay
i'm telling you you're a really good
impressions but after hearing his
impressions of singers it's i know it's
hard to beat that i know
as like singing impressions
you're good at talking impressions he's
gonna you guys should have a show
together
impressionable
um i don't know how much he just has a
beautiful
speaking voice too yes yes he is
resonance rich it's rich
silky
uh and he's sharp you know he's really
quick he is no i like him all right
he has uh like a really good
amount of perspective about his career
and his experience and the mistakes he's
made the mistakes he's made and i it's
it's god impressive person yep yep it
was funny when mom called
and like tried to play it cool by being
uh
by facetime she was like i hope some of
that talent rubs off on you but even the
way she said she goes uh
ugh there's a talent
she said it almost sounded sarcastic
because she was trying she didn't want
to sound too like
excited to see him she loves josh groban
yes cool who doesn't i know i know but
like and she's his target audience too
that's true she's like an art buff
and loves that kind of voice
yeah rich who doesn't rich and creamy
yeah
why yeah what's wrong with that nothing
i guess when you're referring to a voice
but i just think about in the context of
our mother funny when you asked him
where he puts his grammys
oh yeah and he didn't have any i didn't
know that i don't you wouldn't you just
assume that josh groban would have
grammys i would at least one but it's
funny to just
launch into that without knowing hiding
out well that's i would be flattered if
somebody just assumed that i had
you know emmys or oscars yeah
where do you put your oscars
i think you would assume they're making
fun of you oh that's true that's true
you're also not no offense to you no i'm
not you're not the josh groban
uh
equivalent of actors no i know i know
but who is the groban equivalent of
actors gosling
you think wouldn't you assume gosling
had awards for acting doesn't he
uh you know i don't think he has an
oscar weirdly i don't think i think he
might be right that's crazy he should i
should have a handful
yeah that's weird i think you're right
hey they weren't both in the same movie
crazy stupid i love them that's a great
movie
that is a great movie um and he's so
good in it isn't he i mean i haven't
seen that well he's an actor yeah that's
the thing like he happens to have this
amazing i know he had this like crazy
meteoric rise to success with his voice
yeah but
he's an actor he's always wanted to be
an actor yeah it makes sense i mean it's
not in the same way that sara bareilles
don't get me started if i won't uh on
when she was did jesus christ superstar
which you haven't seen it you should
stop this podcast
go find it and watch it and uh get ready
to sit down be sure you're sitting get
ready to go on an emotional well sara
bareilles was also an acapella singer
in college and so it turns out my point
is like i'm sure she was an actress and
i'm sure
if not like
was capable of it all along i also
appreciate that he
he's so in awe of broadway he has this
reverence for musical theater and
stephen sondheim and he talked about
that but he didn't want to use his name
and his celebrity as a singer yeah to
just be stunt cast in some broadway show
which is what they do now you know
because broadway has become the ticket
prices are so astronomically high that's
how i got into a broadway show yeah they
end up no [ __ ] they end up using uh
famous people more than they used to to
cast these roles because they they know
that people will pay top dollar to see
it right um but he didn't want to go
that route which i found pretty
admirable he wanted to come in
and really go through the whole process
because he could have i mean that guy
with that voice and that name i'm sure
he had plenty of opportunities to be in
broadway it speaks to why he was
successful as a singer in the first
place is that he has a work ethic that
is that is admirable that is like
you know it's not like once you get a
name once your name has some value in
the public sphere you just stop fear
you just stop working right
he seems like someone
that uh is you know how people say like
certain people are tough to work with
and that's why they end up
not getting
jobs at a certain point because they're
we all know who they are yeah like
really difficult like pains in the asses
he's not worth it exactly he seems like
the opposite of that in every way he
seems that's true laughable and charming
and really hard-working
and dedicated and
and like fun to be around he seems like
a really fun person to work with yeah
you know they say like i always make
jokes about how if somebody's on the
podcast it doesn't oh it's not gonna
have any effect on their career or it's
like it's it's certainly in a case of
josh groban who like doesn't need any
help by being on a podcast but
if i had heard that if i had heard him
on this
and i was like a movie producer or
something i'd be like i'd be much more
inclined to cast him in something
because i you can hear that he's just
like an easy to work with like good
natured person easy but also extremely
dedicated determined to the crap yeah
whatever the project is to whatever art
it is yeah well he's an artist he is uh
do you want to read a letter yeah yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is from
rosemary
k
subject hi and would you rathers from my
weirdest friend hi christian and justin
i'm so glad i found your podcast during
this crazy time i am glad too rosemary
i'm a speech-language pathologist at a
nursing home and though we have no covet
positive patients yet it's still been a
really hard time for our patients and
their families god i'm sure
no visitors are allowed in the building
and our residents are feeling very
isolated it's heartbreaking to see them
visiting with their family through the
window
or on facetime
yeah god i don't take it for granted
that i'm sometimes the best part of
their day and they are always the best
part of mine oh man nice thing to say
thank you for making me i love that name
rosemary
i like this the seasoning i like the
seasoning and the names just makes me
think of the seasoning which i like you
know both have to like the seasoning
thank you for making me belly laugh
every week ah thanks rosemary
uh listening to your podcast has become
a form of self-care for me so i can
continue to give 100 to my patience
something else that is bringing me joy
is watching my cat sleep
i like watching animals sleep too it's
relaxing yeah i used to have a dog that
uh he had the best dreams you would
twitch and uh sometimes i get jealous of
cats and dogs when i see them when their
paws just start going like they don't
they just don't uh
they're kind of lucky that they don't
have any stresses i think they do have
stress dreams oh they do oh yeah but in
life in general like they just want food
and attention and this dog would always
they're not thinking about kovid no
that's true but but there's i mean who
know they
they're also the mercy of this other
species that like that's true you make a
good argument for humanity yeah
remember when the the
dog
my ex's dog would had his mouth closed
and he'd like bark that's the best when
dogs bark in their in their dreams and
they go
so cute cute anyway um
it's something that is so she says
something that is rosemary something
that is bringing me joy is watching my
castle she's so blissfully unaware of
all the absolute [ __ ] oh happening in
the world like you said and her coziness
is infectious animals are so therapeutic
whether frogs or cats that's true
i would say cats are more yes
i love frogs but on a very different
note i wanted to give you some good
would you rathers great so i reached out
to one of my weirdest friends for some
inspiration here is the list we came up
with in no particular order
would you rather
you ready have you read these
would you rather wear one outfit that
you wore in sixth grade for the rest of
your life or have your sixth grade
haircut for the rest of your life oh
that is good
uh can i pick the outfit
yeah i guess but it has to be something
that you wore in sixth grade by the way
i have a shirt that i love that i wore
in sixth grade that still fits me and i
still love i would wear i would it would
you say that like you're bragging about
it
well i know
you know
i uh do you know what shirt it is no oh
the michael jordan show yeah it's spike
lee oh i like mars blackman
i don't uh
think that what i wore in sixth grade is
that embarrassing or i don't think my
haircut was that embarrassing i was past
the bulk stage oh yeah you had like i
think i had a fine haircut and i think
my clothes were fine weren't we into
like crew cuts then maybe yeah i think
so yeah i think i had a buzz cut i would
both have to get buzz cuts when you're
in middle school i would pick
uh the same haircut because i wouldn't
want to wear the same thing every day
for the rest of my life
it's not that i think either option is
particularly embarrassing that's a good
point but i would pick the haircut i
think i had an okay haircut and if i had
a haircut that i'd have to wear all the
time if i if that were something i had
to do for the rest of my life it would
probably be something akin to a buzz cut
just like shaved easy to manage i
definitely wouldn't have this there i
have now
yeah i wonder if i would have to though
uh
cut all my hair like all my facial like
wax oh yeah face if i had to
have a hair luke of a sixth grader
probably that's a different question and
what outfit would you wear
um
i would that's the thing i wouldn't want
to wear any one but i would wear any of
them yeah
i wore they're not that different from
whatever i wore like jeans and no it's
like shirts sweatshirts yeah
the same thing except the one big change
is i was really into like jerseys of
like players and that's something i find
really nice you can still wear that
though occasionally i mean i i have you
just posted an instagram the other day
where you're wearing a charles shark
lectures
but it's not something i wear
in my day on a date on a date i wouldn't
wear that yes
that's how you know a girl likes you
though if you wear that date and she's
like it's kind of charming and retro and
cute all right date oh interesting date
the next one is date the most annoying
person you know or work a job that you
absolutely hate while being single
forever wait
so so i guess you have to be with
a really the most annoying forever and
the other one is you have a terrible job
and you're single that's two bad things
i would take the one bad thing i would
take dating being stuck with someone i
found annoying because the other option
is is the rest of your life yeah the
other option is you're single and you
hate your job that's true if the first
option is at least would you rather be
with someone you found annoying at but
you loved your job this is like you're
considering two bad things
yeah
uh okay the third one last one
would you rather
poop bricks
poop bricks bricks yeah or snakes
like actual bricks and snakes i guess or
poop that looked like well it wouldn't
be a woody rather if you'd if we didn't
have a poop question
it wouldn't be a show um that's true
bricks that would hurt i'm a snake would
be so much easier to poop yeah but a
living snake well it goes right in the
toilet and i mean all right this is
really disgusting but i would say that
poisonous if the question is poop that
was in the shape of a brick or in the
shape of a snake obviously it's just a
snake i mean
i mean
but if it's a living snake or an actual
absolutely a snake for me
ah
just the comfort of your
butt but steaks bite and if they
wouldn't bite you as it was coming out
how do you know
i i i would i wouldn't i couldn't take
that chance well okay then if it's a
poisonous snake that might bite your
[ __ ] you know what i would do i would
have i would do the bite your scrotum i
would do the brick option and just have
some operation to
make it so that i can easily pass the
brick that's what i would do what
operation
like a butthole enlargement yeah anus
enlargement
i know we'll have to cut this part out
but i really don't want to i i like it'd
be fun to have a show where you don't
have to cut this out maybe we won't have
to who do you have to anus enlargement
can use why not but
to me that's a better option than t
every time i'm going to assume that
rosemary and her weird friend as she
says that's not me calling weird or her
sorry i think it's fair to say that her
friend is weird yeah that's a weird
hybrid which is in a good way yeah our
purposes uh
i would say i'm guessing that the friend
didn't mean a venomous snake like a
[ __ ] cottonmouth or a
some sort of rattlesnake coming out of
your [ __ ] i don't know if she if she
also meant or alive even maybe an actual
brick she may have meant poop in the
shape of a brick
i don't think i don't think so because
that would not be a good hypothetic
that's just an obvious thing not really
not a big long snake
think about it
i am thinking about who cares if it's
long
that would be painful painful in your
body to have a big level no i i think
you're reading too far into it okay
you're reading too far into the colon
of the question um anyway great would
you rather i would say snake for sure uh
and then rosemary says stay safe be well
you two rosemary that is really nice and
what i was just thinking of the anus and
larger
uh thank you rosemary and
and uh how would they do it i mean i
don't know i don't know
does that exist it might exist well some
people maybe are born google is about to
get that yeah
shorties um isn't that funny that well i
think google might get that
search uh okay thank you rosemary thank
you to
the great the great josh groban and uh
thank you to all you who listened of all
different anus sizes
um but josh is awesome and uh yeah
following him on on instagram and
checking he does a lot of stuff and the
charity sounds great yes um
promoting arts education and uh in
schools that's i think that is really
important important and i also like that
he has uh
honed his
charitable outreach to like a very
specific thing i like a lot about that
guy yeah i think you should be friends i
want to be i'm going to try to cultivate
that so wish me luck with my pursuit of
a friendship with josh and uh
yeah thank you all who listened and if
you want to write in oh yes are you like
rosemary yeah even if you don't have as
cool of a name
you could still write in what if she
goes by rose that's the one
reservation i have about that name is
that i like rose too rose is great
rosemary i mean it's three syllables i
you know how i feel about malta oh yeah
um anyway thank you to rosemary and and
write in like rosa did i say the email
uh no you didn't life is short at
wondery.com
oh
and uh
such a silky tone well maybe i'm aware
of my voice now because of our great
voiced uh guest today and uh stay tuned
for a voice memo and we will see
everyone next week
thank you for listening here come life
is short is hosted by me justin long it
is produced by you christian long and
megan monaco senior producer is michelle
mieshlands
his audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marcia louis and
or none lopez or wondering
[Music]
don't you think it's rather
[Music]
and she has such warmth in her warmth
she's so thoughtful yeah that's what it
is she seems like she genuinely cares
about her she and she's really
internalizing everything she's
singing it's so rare there's no like
showing off that's why it seems that
it's so effortless but yeah
and it is like vocally it is because
she's such a trained singer but
it's still still impressive you don't
see any of the like bells and whistles
you don't see any of the work the work
yeah
it's like daniel
[Music]
do
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you